TIM WEINGARTEN: The
Hunt is a community
that provides styling
recommendations and advice
to each other.
One member of The Hunt could
be asking the question of,
what should I wear, and
another member of The Hunt
is answering that
question by providing
products, style recommendations,
advice, and so forth.
The community is
now more productive.
It's working better
than ever before.
And this is due to the
success of our Android app.
JENNY DAVIS: Material
design was a great way
to start building
the Android app.
It was like having a
team of design experts
helping you build the best
product for an Android device.
ALEX FISHWICK: It allowed us
to simplify a lot of the things
that we were trying
to tackle early on.
It's an excellent
structure which
allowed us to just focus on what
was important for our users.
JENNY DAVIS: The Floating
Action button was actually
really intuitive to our users.
We use it for starting a
hunt and adding a find,
our two main actions.
And we've tested it
with our beta testers,
and they just got it.
TIM WEINGARTEN: On Android
with the Play Store,
we are able to iterate as
fast as we do with our web app
today.
We can push our production app
to our user base every day.
That's not possible on
other mobile platforms.
ALEX FISHWICK: If we
were to do it again,
I would definitely go
after Android first.
TIM WEINGARTEN: The results that
have been most compelling to me
are, we had about 15% of our
weekly users starting hunts.
Now on Android, in particular
with material design,
it's increased to 20% of
our Android user base.
We're seeing 150,000
hunts started a week.
And our Android community has
increased our participation
on hunt solving from 10%
of our weekly users to 15%.
The conversation
around what to buy
is not happening
on content sites.
It's not happening on
social media sites.
It's happening in these social
commerce sites like The Hunt.
More and more retailers and
brands are joining The Hunt,
and they're providing
style recommendations
to our community by having
their teams solve hunts.
It doesn't feel
like it's marketing.
It doesn't feel commercial.
It doesn't feel
like advertising.
Because they're really
engaging in a conversation
with their community.
We believe that as
we go international,
as we scale our user
base to tens of millions
of community members,
that The Hunt on Android
will be our platform
to make this happen.